des favorable à vie du gouvernement
avis défavorable
bah tant mes chers collègues
nous allons procéder au vote unique sur
le texte
en application de l'article 44 dernières
années de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf du Règlement du
Sénat
le gouvernement a demandé au Sénat de se
prononcer par un seul vote
sur les articles 9 à 20 on ne retenant à
partir du moment où cette demande a été
formulée que les amendements proposés ou
acceptés par le gouvernement
sans remise en cause des amendements
précédemment adoptés à l'article 9
mais aussi sur l'ensemble du texte
monsieur le ministre
compte tenu des retraits d'amendement
intervenus et pour la clarté la
sincérité de nos débats de notre vote
pouvez-vous nous rappeler la liste des
amendements et sous amendements acceptés
par le gouvernement je vous donne la
parole
merci monsieur le Président voici donc
la liste des amendements et des
sous-allemans et des sous-amendements
acceptés par le gouvernement dans le
cadre du vote unique demande en
application de l'article 44 dernier
alinéa de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 à Linéa neuf du Règlement
du Sénat pardon pour le caractère un peu
un peu fastidieux mais pour l'article 9
les amendements 2133 21 34 21 36 47 61
21 35 21 37 20 30 39 21 43 21 44 21 46
21 47 21 48 21 50 et 21 52 pour
l'article 10 les amendements 21-54 20 59
rectifiés rectifié terre pardon 21 55 20
58 rectifié 20 60 rectifié bis 21 56 21
57 21 58 21 59 21 60 et 46 50
pour les amendements portant
additionnels après l'article 10 les
amendements numéro 22 95 20 24 21 61
rectifié bis 45 47 46 475 rectifié pour
l'article 11 les amendements 24 88
rectifié bis et 21 62 pour les
additionnels après l'article 11
l'amendement 1904 rectifié bis un
article 12 l'amendement 2163 21 64 et 21
pour l'article 13 les amendements 216 21
67 21 69 21 70 21
72 21 73 214 21 75 21 76 21 77 23 60
rectifié bis 21 78 21 79 21 80 21 81 21
82 et 47 57 pour la donc l'article 13
pour les additionnels après l'article 13
les amendements 13 69 et 21 83 pour les
additionnelles avant l'article 14
l'amendement 25 63 rectifié à l'Artic 14
amendement 47 23 à l'article 15 47 24 et
l'article 16 21 84 ainsi que tous les
amendements identiques et à l'exclusion
de tous les autres y compris des
amendements portant un article
additionnel je précise monsieur le
Président quand comparaison avec la
demande formule et vendredi matin le
gouvernement ne retient pas les
amendements 21-41 et 21 45 sur l'article
car ils ont été entre-temps retirés par
le rotor par contre sont inclus les
amendements 46-50 sur l'article 10 et 47
57 sur l'article 13 qui sont des
amendements de coordination présentés
par le gouvernement et que je n'avais
plus présenter lors de la première
déclaration de vendredi matin
merci monsieur le ministre en
application de l'article 42 alinéa 16 de
notre règlement et conformément la
décision de la Conférence des Présidents
lors de sa réunion du mercredi 8 mars je
vous rappelle que les explications de
vote sur l'ensemble de ce projet sont
limités à un orateur par groupe
politique pour une durée de 7 minutes
chacun et un sénateur ne figurant sur la
liste d'aucun groupe pour une durée de 3
minutes je vais maintenant donner la
parole pour explication de vote tout
d'abord pour le groupe les républicains
au président Bruno retaillod
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues enfin nous y
voilà
c'est la fin de ce marathon nous voilà
parvenus au terme de cette course
législative à cet instant que nous
croyons il y a quelques jours encore
inaccessibles nous voilà parvenus à cet
acte le vote qui fonde la légitimité du
Parlement notre raison d'être et je le
pense aussi notre honneur et pourtant
chers collègues de gauche vous avez tout
fait pour empêcher cet acte fondamental
par l'obstruction par l'obstruction plus
de 8000 amendements et de sous
amendements des rappels au règlement en
veux-tu en voilà vous avez été recherché
dans notre règlement toutes les
techniques qui permettaient d'empêcher
d'empêcher le vote vous étiez mauvais
perdant puisque vous aviez par avance
anticipé votre défaite et c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous vouliez
empêcher le vote mais nous y voilà et ce
vote sera pour nous déjà une victoire
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
cette obstruction
vous a permis d'entendre énormément de
prises de parole de nos collègues de
gauche sans que on sache bien qu'elle
s'était vos propositions vos solutions
le Yaka faucon oui le yakafocon oui
souvent mais que faites-vous pour faire
face
à ce grand choc que la France va devoir
dans les prochaines années affronter
l'autre choc il y a bien sûr le choc
climatique mais il y a aussi le choc
démographique du vieillissement les
départs en retraite vont être multipliés
par 4 par 5 que faisons-nous que
voulez-vous faire nous nous agissons
nous avons voulu agir et cette réforme
nous l'avons voulu monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre mais Monsieur le
Ministre du socle tout particulièrement
je voudrais m'adresser à vous
vous irez porter ce message au président
de la République c'est très fort nous
allons la voter mais nous ne souhaitons
pas pour lui c'est très forte nous la
votons parce que c'est notre réforme
c'est ici qu'elle est née nous la
voterons parce que nous l'avons modifié
ces notes que nous allons voter la
surcotte pour les maires de famille
les orphelins handicapés la lutte contre
la fraude
l'emploi des seniors qui sont souvent
trop souvent à l'âge de 57 ou de 58 ans
au chômage les questions de la
pénibilité de l'usure professionnelle ce
sont ces ajouts que nous avons voulu
apporter à ce texte là si nous votons
cette réforme ce n'est pas parce que le
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron la
propose dans c'est pour l'intérêt
national
parce que nous voulons sauvegarder un
régime de retraite par répartition j'ai
entendu les moqueries sur les questions
de chiffres et d'équilibre non ceux qui
se moquent des chiffres se moquent des
français derrière les chiffres il y a
des déficits derrière les déficites il y
a l'argent des Français et derrière
l'argent des Français il y a la peine
des Français
le régime
pas répartition que nous soutenons c'est
celui qu'il faut sauver parce que demain
sinon il y aura un effondrement du
pouvoir d'achat de nos aînés et nos
jeunes devront payer deux fois la
retraite notre votre retraite est leur
propre retraite c'est cela que nous
voulons évidemment préserver comme nous
voulons préserver la croissance de
demain qui est le chemin de la
prospérité et derrière cette réforme il
y a le taux d'emploi il y a cette
capacité que nous aurons de mettre
encore plus de travail dans l'économie
française nous sommes le dernier un des
derniers pays européens par la quantité
de travail et c'est la pauvrissement
assurée si nous en restons là nous
voulons ce chemin de croissance chemin
de prospérité vous voulez la
décroissance le déclassement et la
pauvrissement mais au-delà de ces
considérations
matériel nous nous battons pour quelque
chose de beaucoup plus essentiel que les
retraites ou la croissance nous nous
battons aussi pour des conditions
immatérielles nous nous battons parce
que derrière cette réforme derrière ce
régime intergesse générationnel il y a
un lien il y a ce lien entre les
générations qu'expriment le régime par
répartition et c'est ce lien qui nous
manque tant en France dans une France
archipelisée morcelée fracturé qui
matérialise que nous sommes un peuple
une seule communauté nationale voilà
pourquoi nous allons monsieur le
ministre mesdames Messieurs mes chers
collègues la voté et je terminerai par
des remerciements remerciements d'abord
aux rapporteur au rapporteur à la
rapporteur général qui a fait preuve
d'une grande combativité
[Applaudissements]
remerciements à notre rapporteur à notre
rapporteur René Paul Sabari avec son
énorme travail
avec sa zénitude même sous les attaques
de la gauche bravo chers collègues à
notre président de commission
notre président de commission dont la
voix
au perché se transforme parfois en lames
coupantes et certains le savent ici et
en ont fait les frais merci à tous les
trois je voudrais aussi remercier nos
collègues qui ont été présents regardez
cette présence encore merci mes chers
collègues d'avoir enduré des séances qui
n'apportait souvent rien aucune solution
mais où il fallait faire face aux
manœuvres d'obstruction des oppositions
merci mes chers collègues monsieur le
Président enfin je voudrais terminer une
fois n'est pas coutume parce que je ne
pense pas que dans l'histoire récente du
Sénat notre administration nos services
aient été autant mises à l'épreuve je ne
parle pas de la quantité d'arbres qui
ont dû être abattu pour être transformés
en sous amendement
je parle du travail
je parle du travail de l'administration
du Sénat qui est aussi notre honneur qui
a montré dans des moments extrêmement
tendus difficiles qui a toujours tenu
qui a joué son rôle de conseil parce que
pour nous c'est fondamental je veux
parler bien sûr du secrétaire général de
la séance mais aussi de tous les
collaborateurs et je vous propose
précisément mes collègues pour terminer
ce marathon de vous lever et de les
applaudir
[Applaudissements]
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Monique
Lubin s'exprimer pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
[Applaudissements]
messieurs les ministres madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame et monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues je vais
moi aussi commencer par remercier tous
ceux qui ont travaillé sur ce texte
effectivement très important de cette
mandature
nos collègues
rapporteurs bien évidemment madame la
Présidente de la Commission
l'administration dans son entier tout ce
que l'on voit tous ceux que l'on ne voit
pas et bien évidemment tous nos
collaborateurs soyez remercier de ce
travail extraordinaire de ce travail de
fond pour ceux qui fuient en effet un
marathon
cette journée monsieur les ministres et
Mesdames Messieurs restera une journée
noire pour tous les salariés de ce pays
nous savons que vous voterez le recul de
l'âge de la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
parce que nous savons chers collègues
que vous avez négocié avec le
gouvernement
pour voir aboutir ce que vous attendez
depuis si longtemps
parce que nous savons messieurs les
ministres que le gouvernement s'est
soumis
afin de s'assurer le vote majoritaire du
Sénat dont vous avez impérativement
besoin pour apporter un minimum de
légitimité à votre texte
j'irai droit au but
vous avez voulu faire peur aux Français
en leur disant que les régimes de
retraite étaient en faillite et c'est
faux si c'est faux
votre réforme est une réforme
idéologique
vous n'avez jamais été favorable aux
mesures qui permettent tout salarié de
ce pays de vivre mieux
vous n'avez pas aimé la retraite à 60
ans vous n'aimez pas les 35 heures
vous n'aimez pas tout ce qui dans ce
pays peut servir à asservir un peu moins
tous les salariés votre votre
réforme est injuste elle est injuste
parce qu'elle concerne essentiellement
les salariés les plus proches de leur
départ à la retraite ceux qui
travaillent depuis longtemps ce qui
exerce les métiers les plus difficiles
ce qui perçoivent la plupart du temps
les salaires les plus modestes elle est
brutale parce qu'elle prend effet
immédiatement dès septembre 2023 aucune
réforme depuis celle de 1982 ne s'est
appliqué immédiatement autrement dit à
des salariés dont le départ à la
retraite est prêt ou en cours de
préparation aucune réforme des retraites
n'a jamais été aussi brutal dans ce pays
elle est brutale pour les salariés qui
ont commencé à travailler entre 18 et 20
ans parce qu'il y aura bien un report à
l'âge de 62 ans malgré tous les éléments
de langage que vous avez déployés pour
affirmer cette donne
elle est inéquitable parce que les seuls
efforts vont porter sur les salariés
rien n'est demandé aux employeurs au
prétexte que nous serions déjà trop
exigeant avec les entreprises de ce pays
en termes de cotisation sociale et
d'impôts pourtant depuis cinq ans les
cadeaux fiscaux et sociaux pleuvent sur
les entreprises à un niveau jamais connu
en France
elle est brutale
dans sa toute alité et pour vendre votre
projet de loi
vous avez essayé
de nous compter des histoires
et je mesure mes mots vous savez essayer
de nous vendre
que les femmes y trouveraient leur
compte que les femmes seraient les
grandes gagnantes de cette réforme il
n'en est rien et cela a été démontré
immédiatement c'est tellement faux que
la majorité vous arrache un bonus pour
compenser la perte de bénéfice des
droits familiaux qui s'imposera aux
femmes mères de famille qui devront
travailler deux ans de plus
vous avez aussi essayé c'est presque
encore plus grave c'est au moins aussi
grave de nous faire croire que tous les
salariés qui ont eu une retraite
complète au rétent un minimum de
retraite à 1200 euros brut ça n'est pas
le cas ça a été démontré nous avons eu
même droit à des excès de langage de
certains ministres qui annonçaient 2
millions de bénéficiaires là où on se
rend compte aujourd'hui que ça sera bien
moins que ça elle est brutale avec les
seniors dont tout le monde sait qu'il
rencontre les plus grandes difficultés à
retrouver un emploi ils verront leur
situation se précariser d'autant plus
que vous avez imposé il y a peu une
diminution des droits au chômage
et puis chers collègues je ne vais pas
passer sur la manière dont vous avez que
vous avez eu d'aborder ce texte vous
avez été quasiment mutique durant toute
la durée de son examen nous avons fait
des dizaines et des dizaines de
propositions aucune n'a mérité que vous
vous y intéressiez vous avez refusé le
débat et en le refusant vous avez manqué
de respect à tous ceux qui vont subir
les conséquences de ce report et qui
voulait entendre vos arguments
vous avez certes apporter quelques
nuances pour faire croire que vous
vouliez adoucir un peu la brutalité de
ce texte mais la vérité c'est que vous
vouliez le durcir encore plus en
proposant un amendement monsieur le
Président Retailleau qui revenait sur la
clause du grand-père instaurée par ce
projet de loi c'est-à-dire supprimer les
régimes spéciaux avec effet immédiat
vous n'êtes pas allé au bout parce que
vous risquez d'être mis en minorité et
ça aurait sacrément de permis votre
éventuelle victoire
et que dire en fin de l'attitude du
président de la République
qui refuse obstinément de recevoir les
organisations syndicales après des
semaines de protestation
le peuple gronde et le président de la
République regarde d'ailleurs
cela me fait penser à ce qu'avait dit un
autre président de la République
celui
celui qui nous avait donné la retraite à
60 ans celui qui avait amené des
changements extraordinaires dans les
années 80 pour tous les salariés de ce
pays celui qui nous avait prévenu que
vous toucheriez aux retraites que vous
toucheriez à la protection sociale que
vous vendriez tout au privé nous aurions
dû l'écouter mais cette phrase reste
désormais marquée en nous le président
de la République actuelle n'écoute pas
le peuple le peuple s'en souviendra
merci
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole
pour le groupe de l'Union centriste à
notre collègue Oliviero
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues madame la
Présidente de commission madame mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteur ça y est on y
est alors on va tuer le suspense
majoritairement très majoritairement
notre groupe votre race ce texte on y
est un peu fatigué d'avoir travaillé un
peu fatigué aussi de vous avoir écouté
mes chers collègues
mais on aborde de cette fin de
discussion sans regret sans remords avec
une sérénité un soulagement un
soulagement pour la place et la
crédibilité du Sénat un soulagement pour
notre système de retraite par
répartition un soulagement pour la
démocratie
représentative voilà nous sommes au bout
du texte comme nous l'avait dit le
président vous n'avez pas été pris par
surprise c'était un engagement qui avait
exprimé le Sénat et son président est il
a été capitaine dans la tempête le Sénat
et son président et la majorité
sénatoriale ont tenu leur objectif je
veux remercier à mon tour les présidents
de groupe pour l'organisation des débats
les rapporteurs à un formidable
en argumentation ayant travaillé faisant
notre fierté des batteurs infatigables
ça lui aussi les groupes d'opposition
ils ont fait le choix de la flibusterie
oh disons-le c'était une flibusterie de
notable ça va pas forcément vous faire
plaisir mais c'est ainsi mes chers
collègues
alors ce texte
ce texte
il mérite pas l'indignation que vous lui
avez prêté il mérite pas non plus un
enthousiasme excessif ça n'est pas la
mère des réformes mais il a une utilité
une exigence morale pour les jeunes
générations une utilité parce que
c'était nécessaire alors je vais vous
lire un texte
il n'y a pas d'alternative de nouveaux
efforts notamment des départs à la
retraite plus tardif devront être
réalisés afin de pérenniser notre
système de retraite
je vais répéter on a beaucoup écouté ce
matin on sent la rien lâcher rien lâcher
rien lâcher on revendique à notre tour
le droit à la répétition
et la répétition c'est l'art de la
pédagogie alors il n'y a pas
d'alternative de nouveaux efforts
notamment des départs à la retraite plus
tardif devront être réalisés afin de
pérenniser notre système de retraite
quelle est cet auteur un affreux
réactionnel un conservateur un
rétrograde c'est un nom qui sonne à vos
oreilles c'est Pierre Moscovici mes
chers collègues
ici et donc et lui revendique l'héritage
de la social-démocratie on a entendu
beaucoup de bêtises parfois sur cette
dans cette hémicycle mais je crois que
là tout à l'heure on a touché le fond
pardonnez-moi l'amour des chiffres
ne peut pas faire bon ménage avec
l'amour des gens alors là excusez-moi
j'ai entendu ça tout à l'heure voilà la
responsabilité c'est qu'elle sait
l'amour des chiffres et c'est l'amour
des gens et je pense que vous avez cité
Pierre Mauroy si Jacques Delore avait
entendu que l'amour des chips était
incompatible avec l'amour des gens je
pense qu'il aurait réagi dans cette
assemblée c'est un soulagement pour nos
systèmes de retraite un soulagement pour
les retraités parce que évidemment il y
a ceux qui manifestent mais il y a aussi
minorité majorité je sais pas
silencieuse les retraités qui après le
vote de ce texte sont sécurisés par
rapport à leur retraite et par rapport
leur risque qui pouvait y avoir sur la
baisse des retraites les jeunes qui vont
pas devoir payer deux fois une double
peine payer leur retraite mais aussi
payer la dette parce que qu'est-ce qu'il
y a de plus irresponsable que de payer
les dettes à crédit nous ne faisons pas
ce choix du paiement des dettes à crédit
c'est irresponsable
ce texte ça a été dit il y a des
avancées les seniors le CDI seniors bien
sûr que le travail plus longtemps pour
les seniors c'est la clé ça a été dit
par Elisabeth par René Paul la question
des familles des carrières longues la
politique familiale la question de
l'égalité homme-femme les tuques chers
collègues faudra pas en ayant pas voter
steaks revendiquer des avantages ou une
justice pour l'étude les pompiers mes
chers collègues et puis les élus grâce à
Sylvie vermeiller les mers et les élus
pourront et c'est pas voir les choses
par le petit bout de la lorgnette
excusez-moi pourront racheter des
trimestres pour les élus qui gagnent
moins de 1830 euros par mois mais ce
texte n'est pas un chèque en blanc il y
a beaucoup de choses qu'il faudra
aborder la question de la justice bien
sûr cette réforme des retraites ne peut
pas tout la question du sens du travail
on n'est pas acharné on croit la valeur
travail mais bien évidemment il faut la
qualité de de vie au travail il faut la
formation tout au long de la vie il faut
travailler sur l'autonomie il faut une
grande loi travail nous sommes partisans
de cette grande loi travail et puis il
faut un dialogue social
et ça nous y tenons beaucoup un
paritarisme rénové refondé et c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec Hervé
Marseille nous demandons l'ouverture le
plus vite possible d'une conférence
sociale et puis sur la g par et pour la
démocratie représentative les
institutions de la 5ème sont solides
tant mieux mes chers collègues parce que
sans ces articles on n'y serait pas
arrivé vous savez Aristote disait la
politique c'est la rhétorique mais c'est
aussi l'action et la délibération et
donc l'obstruction parlementaire c'est
une impasse ah encore un affreux
réactionnaire c'est Laurent Berger qui
dit ça
alors il y aura un avant et un après on
a entendu un avant et un après mais oui
mais surtout sur votre banc on a cité
tout à l'heure Alfred Jarry les vorace
et les curiasses et bien oui mes chers
collègues les voraces ont battu les
coriaces comme dans Alfred Jarry mais
c'est la gauche radicale qui a écrasé la
sociale démocratie dans vos rangs voilà
la réalité de ce débat et c'est en ça
que plus rien ne sera pareil on a eu
donc une gauche sur rassembler sur le
plus petit dénominateur commun celui de
la radicalité alors pour conclure je
voudrais citer Charles de Gaulle la
politique la plus coûteuse mes chers
collègues la plus ruineuse pour le
peuple c'est d'être petit et bien cette
citation je vous l'envoie en cadeau le
Sénat sort renforcé les institutions
sont solides la démocratie
représentative est plus crédible et nous
sommes fiers les uns et les autres
d'appartenir à cette majorité
sénatoriale je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au président François
Patriat pour le groupe il y aura
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la parole
c'est le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur madame la Présidente
le choix que nous allons opérer ce soir
est un choix de responsabilité et un
choix d'efficacité
inutile d'être
vindicatif agressif ou caricatural il va
de l'avenir des générations futures il y
va de l'équilibre de nos systèmes
sociaux demain
je voudrais dire ici que notre assemblée
sur le président a redonné de la
noblesse au débat au débat démocratique
sans noblesse à la fois de débattre le
temps qu'il a fallu trois écouter le
temps de demain nous aussi la noblesse
de décider parce qu'une assemblée qui
débat sans voter au bout s'auto immunise
ou s'auto détruits par rapport à son
rôle initial quand comment s'est déroulé
ce débat mes chers collègues s'est
déroulé en demi-temps sportif comme vous
première mi-temps du 2 au 7 pendant
cette première mi-temps chacun a pu
s'exprimer longuement je vous rappelle
que ce débat a donné lieu à presque 5000
amendements à 10 jours de débat du sans
précédent sur le débat sur les retraites
les trois débats sur les traits qui ont
eu lieu jusqu'à présent se dérouler dans
un climat plutôt serein ou l'opposition
souhaitait montrer son soutien à la rue
au débat syndical par ailleurs et
arriver à ce débat première mi-temps qui
se déroulait avec une multitude
d'amendements de non je me souviens sur
l'article liminaire 52 prises de parole
les unes les mêmes que les autres pour
pouvoir faire supprimer cet article
luminaire je m'en souviens
inutile et puis à partir du 7 la
deuxième mi-temps les masques sont
tombés les masques sont tombés parce que
et parce que sont tombés parce que la
volonté de l'opposition n'était pas tant
de débattre ce qu'elle a affirmé voulu
pendant des jours et des jours mais la
volonté de l'opposition était de faire
en sorte que nous ne puissions pas voter
et vous l'avez dit clairement vous
l'avez dit clairement dans cet assemblée
dans les couloirs et dans les réunions
des présidents vous l'avez dit ne pas
voter pourquoi pour tenter de légitimer
un texte
voté par le Parlement or à qui
appartient la légitimité dans ce pays la
légitimité l'appartient au Parlement
elle appartient pas à la rue vous dire
ce que vous voulez c'est le Parlement
qui décide aujourd'hui et vous savez
d'affronter la rue c'est pas toujours
facile c'est pas toujours facile de
voter des textes un populaire c'est pas
toujours facile d'appeler à l'effort
c'est pas toujours facile d'appeler à la
raison il y a des gens ici qui ont pris
le responsabilité qui l'ont fait alors
le choix de la responsabilité de la
sécurité et de l'efficacité nous l'avons
fait y a t-il eu un bayonnement chers
collègues chers collègues nous avons
écouté et vous nous reprochez parfois
d'avoir été muet mais vous répétiez sans
arrêt les mêmes choses pour occuper le
temps et à chaque fois le rapporteur les
rapporteurs vous aurez répondu
techniquement à fond au débat sur ces
sujets le gouvernement vous a apporté à
chaque fois par le ministre les réponses
qu'il avait à apporter il l'a fait il
n'y a pas eu de ballonnements y a-t-il
eu du mépris
à quel moment qui a maîtrise et qui
est-ce que par le fait que sur un texte
de loi annoncé aux Français travailler
depuis des mois décidez demain en quoi
les pénétrer le président de la
République ne méprise pas les syndicats
il les a il les a reçus il les a reçu au
printemps il a fait en sorte qu'ils
entrent au CNR la CGT a refusé de
participer à la rencontre à l'Élysée de
dites pas que les mépris elle a refusé
mes chers collègues elle a refusé d'y
aller il voulait aujourd'hui il n'y a il
n'y a pas eu de brutalité
un texte qui est débattu depuis quatre
ans ici et on dort cet assemblée avec
des rencontres avec tous les syndicats
un débats qui a été mené au fond par le
ministre ici présent par madame la
Première ministre avec les syndicats
pour aboutir à des avancées notoires que
les syndicats ont reconnu en privé mais
n'ont jamais voulu
accepter en public par ailleurs jamais
et ça tu fais donc il n'y a pas eu de
brutalité il y a eu un texte et moi je
le rappelle ici quitte à vous faire
crier ou vous faire maintenant je trouve
que ce texte il est à la fois nécessaire
et protecteur et d'ailleurs les Français
ne citeront pas quand ils disent
aujourd'hui à 8 pour 10 qu'il pense que
le texte sera voté ça n'est pas par
notre entêtement parce qu'ils savent
très bien en eux-mêmes que ce texte il
est nécessaire pour assurer la survie la
survie du service pour demain et ils le
savent ils le savent très bien il y a
pas eu de brutalité parce que le parce
que les discussions ont eu lieu il n'y a
pas eu de brutalité parce que le madame
la Première ministre a reçu combien de
fois les syndicats en quoi est-ce que le
gouvernement aujourd'hui n'est-il pas
autorisé ou fait pour faire ce débat
alors voilà ce texte je le dis il est
d'abord nécessaire je crois que vous
avez utilisé les rapports du corps
qu'est-ce que dit le corps le corps dit
que dans la situation la plus favorable
il y aura 13 milliards de déficit en
2030 et qu'il faut les combler
aujourd'hui vous dites que ce texte est
injuste ce qui est juste demain ce n'est
pas de travailler plus aujourd'hui
injuste ce qui est injuste c'est de
laisser à nos enfants un système en
perdition des retraites au rabais et une
dette supérieure pour la France voilà ce
qui est injuste aujourd'hui voilà ce qui
est induit alors je vous dis moi les
chers collègues
je vous le dis franchement maintenant
nous allons voter ce texte parce que
nous pensons qu'il était non seulement
nécessaire mais qu'il est efficace aussi
et ce que je vous le dis le ministre
vous la redit l'autre jour ce texte une
fois voté vous pensez qu'il va laisser
de la rancœur de la fracture qui paiera
aux élections
je ne sais pas si ça va m'arranger
électoralement ou pas électoralement ce
que je sais est-ce qu'il est bon pour
payer ou est-ce qu'il est nécessaire et
je le sais comme tel et demain je vous
l'assure je suis le ministre monsieur le
ministre vous l'a dit aucun gouvernement
ne reviendra sur ce texte comme ça a été
fait par le passé vous pouvez dire
aujourd'hui ce que vous voulez vous-même
si un jour vous accédez aux
responsabilités que je ne souhaite pas
vous ne reviendriez pas dessus et vous
aurez à redire les propos que vous avez
tenu aujourd'hui alors voilà mes chers
collègues se présente je vais conclure
je voudrais à mon tour remercier ici
remercier la Commission et les
rapporteurs qui ont répondu avec
beaucoup de sérénité beaucoup
d'efficacité au fond aux arguments
parfois fallacieux vous avez pu
développer et remercier Monsieur le
Ministre ici qui a fait preuve d'une
constance d'une pédagogie d'une
connaissance des dossiers que j'ai
admiré moi-même je porte monsieur le
mini cousin est un grand militante à
faire je vous en remercie
monsieur le président
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Cathy à Boursault poli pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous y sommes la
droite sénatoriale s'apprête à voter
cette réforme scélérate de recul de
l'âge de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
elle s'apprête à le faire main dans la
main avec le gouvernement et laisse
sénatrice et sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle vous avez pu parvenir à
ce moment du vote malgré la contrainte
de l'article 47 1 de la Constitution
parce que vous avez ensemble
gouvernement et majorité sénatoriale
usé de toutes les procédures
réglementaires et constitutionnelle
possible et inimaginable pour accélérer
les débats en censurant l'opposition de
la gauche sénatoriale
vous avez bloqué la démocratie le
blocage c'est vous ce projet de loi est
fondamental pour des millions de nos
concitoyens et de nos concitoyennes ils
veulent deux années de retraite en bonne
santé à ces travailleurs et travailleurs
qui quel que soit leur corps de métier
aspirent au repos ce projet de loi c'est
aussi la nouvelle attaque contre les
régimes spéciaux régimes pionniers qui
concerne des professions rudes votez la
fin du régime spécial des électriciens
gaziers au moment où ils sont mobilisés
dans des conditions très difficiles
suite aux intempéries de ces dernières
48 heures est une insulte pour eux
monsieur le ministre vous vous êtes
empêtrés pour faire prendre des vessies
pour des lanternes à votre peuple en
affichant des avancées sur leur carrière
longue ou sur le revenu minimum de 1200
euros avancé qui s'avère lilliputienne
et même inconsistante
vous avez multiplié dissimulations et
contre vérités pour tenter de rendre
acceptable votre texte vous avez échoué
la toile de fond reste la même et
personne n'est dupe vous voulez reculer
l'âge de départ à la retraite ce projet
de loi vous l'avez aggravé mesdames et
messieurs de la droite sénatoriale
comment ne pas évoquer l'introduction
par vos soins du verre dans le fruit des
retraites avec votre amendement sur la
capitalisation vous avez tombé le masque
votre choix c'est celui des fonds de
tension vous vous attaquer au régime par
répartition pour rendre de fait
obligatoire le recours aux assurances
privées nous l'avons dit d'entrer vous
violez la Constitution à double titre
d'une part en empêchant le débat
parlementaire et d'autre part en mettant
le principe républicain reconnu par le
préambule de la Constitution de 1946
issus du programme du Conseil National
de la Résistance
mais pour vous monsieur le ministre il
n'y a pas de principe votre priorité
n'est pas leur bien-être c'est d'éviter
de demander au plus riche et au patronat
de payer de ne pas mettre la main à la
poche parce que finalement il n'y a que
ça qui vous intéresse avec vos nouveaux
alliés de la droite sénatoriale vous
avez refusé d'examiner sérieusement nos
propositions
alternatives au financement oui il est
possible de rétablir la retraite à 60
ans véritable projet de justice sociale
à l'heure ou des progrès scientifiques
et technologiques
partagez les richesses partagez le
travail pensez à un monde plus juste
humain qui parle un projet de
transformation sociale et écologique est
une alternative complète à votre projet
libéral projet d'un vieux monde où seul
la concurrence et le profit ne trouve
grâce à vos yeux ce projet il grandit
dans notre peuple que vous le vouliez ou
pas il grandit en Europe et dans
l'esprit de tous les peuples du monde
cette réforme des retraites c'est une
réforme rétrograde un projet de classe
contre classe pour l'imposer vous avez
donc choisi le coup de force
anti-démocratique tous les moyens sont
bons pour vous du détournement initial
de la Constitution pour corseter le
débat à l'application du vote bloqué au
Sénat votre choix c'est
l'autoritarisme Emmanuel Macron refuse
de recevoir les syndicats Unis quand
votre projet affirme dans une dérive
bonapartiste assumer ne par les cops
mais enfin écoutez justement le peuple
qui est vend debout vent debout quand
votre réforme et écoutez-le une fois
pour toute le coup de force
anti-démocratique avec le non vote de
l'Assemblée nationale et le vote bloqué
le vote forcer du Sénat rend illégitime
cette réforme des retraites
rétrograde monsieur Macron veut
s'adresser au peuple qu'il le fasse en
organisant un référendum avec cette
question Êtes-vous pour ou contre le
recul à 64 ans de l'âge de départ à la
retraite
pour ouvrir cette porte de sortie
démocratique à la grave très grave crise
sociale et politique que nous vivons
retirez votre projet
retirez-le avant que la colère populaire
ne vous atteigne cette réforme est
illégitime je le redis nous l'avons dit
sans cesse sur les bancs de la gauche
comme le brandissait une dame cet
après-midi à la manifestation à Paris
sur une pancarte
je suis fatigué
laissez-moi laissez-nous enfin le temps
d'être heureux et heureuse alors retrait
de cette réforme à 64 ans et croyez-nous
croyez moi nous irons jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue Henri
Cabanel pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la Présidente les
affaires sociales madame et monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
mon groupe est déçu déçu par cette
mascarade de débat les yeux étaient
rivés sur le Sénat nous aurions pu
montrer la raison la conscience aux
Français qui attendaient beaucoup de
notre assemblée les Français qui pour la
sauvegarde du régime à répartition était
essentiel après le spectacle désolant de
l'Assemblée nationale nous aurions pu
sortir ressortir grandi
naïvement j'y croyais mais le scénario
était écrit d'avance les uns et les
autres se rejetant la responsabilité de
cet échec pourtant pourtant il y a eu de
moments rares trop rares de débats
intéressants
bien sûr notre Constitution ainsi que
notre règlement prévoit tous les cas de
figures pour l'examen des textes de loi
bien sûr nous avons des droits pour
défendre des amendements
mais que dire des dizaines de prises de
parole sur des rappels au règlement ou
sur des dizaines d'amendements
identiques bien avant l'article 17 sur
l'âge de départ à la retraite
ce n'est pas comme cela que l'on fait
entendre nos voix ni qu'on gagne des
voix
bien sûr le gouvernement a des droits
aussi pour recourir aux 44 3 nous
privant ainsi de débats dans la deuxième
partie le scénar aussi à travers son
règlement mais devait-on en arriver là
que dire de la méthode sur le véhicule
législatif sur le rejet de la réforme
par tous les partenaires sociaux sans
oublier les nombreuses personnes dans
les rues
nous avions aussi des devoirs ceux de ne
pas priver les Français d'un débat
d'idée de leur offrir la possibilité
d'améliorer ce texte sur des sujets
primordiaux je passe aux aménagements
pour les carrières longues à
l'amélioration des droits à pension pour
les femmes les étudiants les sportifs
les personnes en situation d'handicap ou
encore pour tous ceux qui s'engagent à
cet égard j'espère que la mannement de
mon groupe en faveur des pompiers
volontaires résistera comme bout
beaucoup d'autres que nous avons pu
malgré tout faire adopter dans le
brouillard de ses débats
pour aller encore plus au fond de tout
cela était-il trop demandé de tout
simplement débattre avec une envie
véritable d'aller d'avancer d'aller
jusqu'au bout du texte notre devoir
était de montrer notre sincérité à mon
avis nous n'avons pas atteint ces
objectifs loin de là
l'image est désastreuse et notre
responsabilité je pense et collégiale
et comment avec cela réconcilier les
Français avec la politique ils sont
complètement écœurés par ces méthodes et
complètement déconnectée on le serait à
moins
ces stratagèmes de vieilles politiques
ne serviront pas à notre corps à notre
noble cause la colère et la déception
génère des votes extrêmes et certains
sont tombés dans le piège de la terre
tradition qui ne leur a servi qui ne
donnera qui ne leur sera d'aucun
bénéfice pardon car aujourd'hui le parti
qui gagne et celui de la tension
souvenons-nous tous des dernières
élections
ce qui s'est passé au Parlement sur ce
texte laissera des traces c'est bien
dommage car je suis certain qu'au fond
tous ensemble nous sommes tous d'accord
pour dire que notre démocratie vieux
vaut mieux que cela
au bout de ce tunnel de discussion
chacun des membres de bons groupes
votera se lancer cela on s'est
convictions et je voudrais aussi
remercier tous mes collègues qui pendant
ces 10 jours ont été présents ainsi que
remercier tous nos collaborateurs
pour ma part je crois toujours à la
nécessité d'une réforme la stratégie
d'évitement mise en œuvre depuis 10
jours n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
reculer pour mieux sauter ne présage en
rien de bon car cette hypothéqué
l'avenir dans notre système de retraite
par répartition
menacée par une logique démographique
implacable un système auquel sont
attachés nos concitoyens faut-il le
rappeler aussi il est au cœur du pacte
social de notre République il mérite
d'être sauvé son équilibre ainsi que ses
partenaires fondamentaux dont celui très
important de la solidarité je vous
remercie si chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole au président
cloud Malhuret pour le groupe Les
Indépendants une république et
territoire
monsieur le président
monsieur le Président vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le rapporteur spécial mes chers
collègues
en 1981 le premier président de gauche
de la Cinquième République a voulu faire
croire aux Français que la situation de
notre pays nous permettait d'abaisser
l'âge de la retraite à 60 ans que nous
serions des précurseurs et que les
autres pays développés ne tarderaient
pas à nous emboîter le pas 10 ans plus
tard après le déclassement économique
des années 80 et après que nos voisins
européens aient choisi le chemin
exactement inverse qui consiste à
augmenter l'âge de la retraite parfois
jusqu'à 67 ans un autre homme de gauche
qui n'était pas lui un démagogue Michel
Rocard expliquait qu'il fallait
d'urgence revenir en arrière mais
ajouter que ce retour à la réalité
ferait chuter 4 gouvernements il n'était
pas loin de la vérité
depuis 30 ans plusieurs gouvernements
ont tenté de réformer le système pour
éviter les déficits abisseaux qui
s'annonçaient certains ont échoué comme
en 95 d'autres ont réussi auprès d'une
part d'une impopularité certaine d'autre
part d'une limitation forcée de leurs
objectifs qui n'ont jamais permis de
résoudre le problème du déficit
structurel dû à la chute permanente du
nombre de cotisants par rapport à celui
des retraités ce fut le cas en 93 en
2003 en 2010 et pour la première fois et
pour la dernière fois pardon en 2013
sous la présidence de François Hollande
je suis d'ailleurs surpris que ceux qui
ont défendu à l'époque cette réforme en
constatant son inévitable impopularité
et en sachant pertinemment qu'elle ne
résoudrait les problèmes que pour un
temps soit aujourd'hui dans le camp des
adversaires acharnés de la réforme
actuelle comme s'ils ignoraient sa
nécessité
on dit souvent que l'on peut faire dire
aux chiffres ce que l'on veut mais
lorsque l'on parle d'un déficit pour le
système de retraite de 150 milliards
cumulés d'ici 10 ans comment nier la
nécessité d'une nouvelle réforme s'il
est un objectif sur lequel nous pouvons
tous nous mettre d'accord c'est la
préservation de notre régime par
répartition et ce n'est pas en laissant
croître le déficit que l'avenir de ce
système sera assuré diminuer les
pensions est inacceptables dans un
contexte où l'inflation s'installe
durablement et ronge de pouvoir d'achat
augmenter les cotisations est
inenvisageable dans un pays déjà
médaille d'or au championnats du monde
des prélèvements obligatoires reste donc
le report de l'âge légal de la de départ
à la retraite c'est la solution retenue
par ce projet de loi et c'est celle qui
nous paraît la meilleure non pas la plus
agréable ou la plus populaire mais la
meilleure en tout cas la plus juste et
la moins mauvais pendant de très longues
heures nous avons entendu à de nauséames
plusieurs groupes ne s'est assemblés
ravâché d'autres pistes de financement
un inventaire à la Prévert de taxes
supplémentaires augmentation de la CSG
contribution exceptionnelle sur ceci ou
cela taxe sur les robots et j'en passe
et des meilleurs mais au fond rien de
cela ne devrait nous surprendre nous
écoutons souvent ces mêmes propositions
lors de l'examen du budget cette fois le
prétexte et le financement du système de
retraite mais l'objectif reste toujours
le même taxer plus
notre système de retraite doit pouvoir
s'équilibrer par les cotisations
prélevées sur les salaires il a été
construit ainsi il doit évoluer avec la
réalité et non pas contraire bien sûr il
est nécessaire de prendre en compte les
situations particulières des Français ce
débat au Parlement était l'opportunité
d'amander le texte en étant force de
proposition c'est pourquoi notre groupe
apporté des amendements pour mieux
protéger les plus précaires de nos
concitoyens de tenir compte des
carrières longues et de ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt de ceux qui
exercent un travail pénible tous les
jours et qui doivent avoir le droit de
partir plus tôt en retrait des mers dont
la carrière est parfois pénalisée par
leur maternité alors même que la
natalité est un des facteurs clés de
notre modèle par répartition des aidants
qui vivent parfois des situations
extrêmement difficiles et qui doivent
être encouragés ou encore des pompiers
volontaires qui risquent leur vie et qui
méritent notre reconnaissance
malheureusement
une partie du débat a été confisqué par
la gauche
sans avoir su convaincre nos concitoyens
au cours des derniers scrutins
sans avoir su proposer des solutions
viables pour notre système de retraite
elle n'a cherché qu'à retarder nos
débats en déposant plus de 8000
amendements et sous amendements en
déposant des dizaines voire des
centaines d'amendements de suppression
sur chaque article en déposant des
amendements identiques qui déclinaient à
même dispositif en ne changeant qu'un
seul chiffre en passant des heures
entières de séances à faire des rappels
au règlement qui n'en n'était pas
vraiment les groupes de gauche ont
choisi une stratégie d'obstruction
délibérée et constante avec pour seul
objectif la non d'adoption du texte ils
ne s'en sont d'ailleurs pas cachés
je suis navré de devoir le rappeler mais
il n'y a pas en démocratie de minorité
de blocage ce n'est pas parce qu'une
minorité refuse de voter un texte
qu'elle doit empêcher la majorité de le
faire et je voudrais aussi rappeler que
dans une démocratie la loi ne se fait
pas dans la rue mais au Parlement
[Applaudissements]
et au Parlement la grande hypocrisie de
ce débat c'est que la gauche s'indigne
aujourd'hui de l'utilisation de
l'article 44.3 de notre loi fondamentale
alors même qu'elle y a allègrement
recouru pour faire adopter la réforme
Touraine qu'elle portait dans 2013 et 9
fois au cours du mandat de François
Hollande
nous n'ignorons pas que cette réforme
est un populaire et pour cause elle
existe des efforts supplémentaires de
tous les Français alors même qu'ils ont
fournissent déjà beaucoup mais c'est
précisément parce qu'il s'agit d'une
réforme aussi nécessaire que délicate
que le Parlement se devint d'aller au
bout de son examen ce n'est pas en
fuyant nos responsabilités que nous
ferons honneur à notre mandat et je
voudrais après les orateurs qui m'ont
précédé remercier notre président les
ministres qui sont restés au banc
pendant ces 10 jours la présidente de la
commission la rapporteur général le
rapporteur spécial et tous nos collègues
dont le dont la patience a été mise à
rude épreuve et enfin l'ensemble du
personnel du Sénat qui a participé à
tous ces jours de discussion l'avenir
des français est en jeu le texte que
nous examinons depuis plusieurs jours
est essentiel à bien des égards car
c'est la survie du régime par
répartition qui est en
parce qu'il s'agit d'un projet de loi
nécessaire
responsable et juste notre groupe votera
en faveur de cette réforme
[Applaudissements]
à Madame Raymonde ponts c'est bon pour
le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
vous avez la parole si monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègue cette réforme des retraites est
une des plus importantes de ce
quinquennat
car à travers elle c'est le système
productif et le contrat social qui sont
en jeu c'est le travail l'emploi mais
aussi les conditions de travail c'est le
temps libéré du travail subordonné la
place des activités non marchande ce
sont toutes les problématiques sociales
qui sont ici convoquées l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé le handicap la part
du travail dans la répartition des
richesses
l'invalidité l'inaptitude c'est
l'exclusion sociale la précarité la
pauvreté qui ont été questionnées c'est
la place du prendre soin de l'autonomie
des aidants c'est la place des services
publics et les conséquences de la baisse
des effectifs et du gels du point
d'indice des fonctionnaires c'est la
place des femmes des personnes immigrées
et plus largement la question des
discriminations sur le marché dans
l'emploi qui sont mises en avant
la retraite ne peut être traitée avec
une règle de trois budgétaires c'est un
projet de société ces questions aurait
mérité d'être débattues questionnés
interrogés faire l'objet de controverse
or nous nous sommes heurté un mur
anti-démocratique pour bâillonner la
minorité parlementaire d'abord par le
silence d'abord par le silence et la
passivité de la droite sur nos
propositions d'amendements pour résoudre
le problème des ressources puisque le
problème nous le rappelons ce n'est pas
la dynamique des dépenses de retraite
puis du 47 ans ou 44,3 de la
constitution du 42 9 de notre règlement
la mobilisation de tous les outils
possibles pour imposer l'examen express
de nos amendements après le recours
abusif aux irrecevabilité après le
retrait d'amendement de la majorité de
droite pour faire tomber les nôtres puis
l'interdit d'expliquer nos votes dans un
débat des dans un sénat dévitalisé de
toutes les confrontations des arguments
et ceci ceci pour aboutir le plus vite
possible au vote seul enjeu de la droite
et du gouvernement un vote actant au
plus vite la collusion de la droite
sénatoriale et du gouvernement pour
gagner une course de vitesse face à une
mobilisation qui monte croissante
inédite déterminée une mobilisation
d'une majorité de Français de la
quasi-totalité des actifs déjà des
femmes de toutes les catégories
socio-professionnelles et surtout de
l'ensemble des syndicats de salariés
unis dans une intersey syndicale
historique et faisant du refus du recul
de l'âge d'ouverture des droits de la
retraite à la retraite une question non
négociable une course de vitesse pour
plier le débat car jamais jamais un
texte n'a été autant un peu populaire
la pièce qui s'est joué au Sénat créa
précédent et être dangereuse pour
l'avenir de la démocratie parlementaire
et pour la confiance de la population
envers la démocratie représentative ce
qui s'est produit ne profitera aucun de
ses acteurs ni à la droite qui croit
avoir enfin obtenu la victoire de leurs
projets régressif ni au gouvernement qui
se croit libéré d'une bataille alors
qu'il a perdu tout soutien dans la
population et donc toutes légitimité
sociale et morales toutes les victoires
arrachées par le pouvoir au corps
défendant du peuple sont rendus
possibles par un glissement autoritaire
qui nous éloigne des principes dont le
corps politique se revendique pourtant
la liberté et la démocratie la façon
dont le gouvernement impose son projet
avec la complicité de la majorité
conservatrice du Sénat annonce une aire
in libérale où l'extrême droite ne sera
que la seule bénéficiaire car nous le
savons cette réforme antisociale des
retraites n'était pas nécessaire et le
déficit y a été construit par la non
volonté d'y allouée des ressources
l'ensemble de nos propositions ont été
balayées alors qu'elles étaient juste
socialement et durable tant sur le plan
financier qu'environnemental les 18 les
18 milliards ne seront générés que par
le monde du travail nullement sur le
capital nullement sur les très hauts
patrimoine nullement sur les
bénéficiaires depuis 2017 du désarmement
fiscal uniquement sur les travailleurs
travailleuses et des travailleurs qui
verront s'éloigner l'horizon de leur vie
hors travail
ces années de travail supplémentaires ne
sont plus permise par l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie elles sont prises sur
la durée de la retraite qui diminue
désormais on cessera alors le travail
plus proche de la mort c'est peut-être
ce qu'ils font inconsciemment la force
du refus ces années de plus sont prises
sur l'espérance de vie en bonne santé ou
prolonge une situation de pauvreté de
précarité pour faire passer cela nous
avons assisté à une exaltation du
travail comme si tout travail était par
construction par définition émancipateur
et comme si refusait de le prolonger
sans fin était la négation de sa place
venant d'un gouvernement qui nie la
pénibilité du travail rien de nouveau à
défaut de changer les choses on change
les mots pour les maçons les aides à
domicile les chauffeurs de bus les
égoutiers les professeurs les soignants
les agriculteurs les employés les
ouvriers
travail et surtout à partir d'un certain
âge peut être si une souffrance qui
abime les corps et les esprits et toutes
les statistiques montrent que cela est
de plus en plus vrai or qu'avons-nous
pour elle et eux dans ce texte à part un
index non contraignant que le Conseil
constitutionnel risque d'exclure comme
cavalier social quand on mesure
d'atténuation de la brutalité de cette
réforme elles ont été évoquées dans un
combat sans contradictoire et c'était
mieux vu les mensonges quant aux trois
milliards annoncés pour l'incapacité
permanente c'est un mensonge inexiste
pas puisque rien ne change sur ce point
vous votez cette réforme contre le
peuple vous votez cette réforme au nom
de l'avenir avec un logiciel du passé le
sens de l'histoire c'était et cela reste
la retraite à 60 ans c'est la baisse du
temps de travail et la transformation de
notre modèle de production et de
consommation
la reconnaissance des activités selon
leur utilité sociale et non au profit de
la croissance sans fin de la richesse de
quelques heures nous ne voterons pas
cette réforme pas uniquement pour les
raisons que nous avons développé mais
parce que nous avons un autre projet
celui de l'écologie sociale ce soir la
bataille au Sénat aboutit à un vote de
la droite pour sauver le gouvernement
mais la bataille contre cette loi
continue et autant qu'il le faudra la
gauche les écologistes l'amèneront
jusqu'au retrait
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président kaner monsieur le
Président Monsieur les ministres
cette réforme a été présenté merci de la
parole monsieur le Président cette
réforme a été présenté comme la mère de
toutes les réformes et vous savez que
pour nous en tout cas elle constituera
une
régression sociale pour plusieurs
millions de nos concitoyens qui seront
malheureusement à payer un impôt mais un
impôt sur leur vie de retraite c'est une
réforme donc essentielle mes chers
collègues et nous pensons au nom des
trois groupes de gauche ici présents et
mes collègues associés et gontards et
tous les collègues ici présents 30
signataires demandent l'application de
l'article 51 de notre règlement à savoir
que la présence dans l'enceinte du
palais de la majorité absolue des
sénateurs est nécessaire pour la
validité des votes sauf en matière de
fixation de l'ordre du jour donc
monsieur le Président je sollicite votre
part cette constatation éventuelle
bien monsieur le président
s'il vous plaît
je suis saisi d'une demande écrite
monsieur le Président par vous-même de
vérification du corps en application de
l'article 51 alignéa III du règlement la
constatation du nombre des présents est
effectué sur la demande écrite de 30
sénateurs dont la présence doit être
constatée par appel nominal il va donc
être procédé à l'appel nominal des
signataires de la demande de
vérification du Corum et les huissiers
vont donc effectuer cet appel à vous
madame Cathy
Éliane
c'est David Assouline
Florence blatrix
Madame Corinne Ferret
monsieur
Monsieur Patrick
on l'avait déjà dit
monsieur Gérard Laennec
madame Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie
Monsieur Pierre Laurent
madame Annie le héros madame Monique
Lubin
madame Michel meunier
madame Marie-Pierre Monnier
Monsieur Franck Montauger Madame
Raymonde ponts
madame Emilienne Poumirol
monsieur Lucien Stanzione
monsieur Rachid
monsieur Jean-Claude Tissot
madame Sabine
madame Mélanie Vogel
chers collègues je constate
je constate
que la présence d'au moins 30 sénateurs
est effective il peut être procéder à la
vérification du Corum
je vais procéder la vérification du
Corum j'invite donc en application de
l'article 51 ligne 2 du règlement de
secrétaire à venir m'assister en
l'occurrence Monsieur Jacques reperain
et Monsieur Jean-Claude Tissot
et ces histoires de mon infirmique deux
fois non pardon
il y a une erreur
pouvez-vous venir à mes côtés avant que
je procède
après contrôle
il n'y a pas 30 sénateurs mais 29
[Applaudissements]
je vais donc mettre au voile
s'il vous plaît
je vais mettre au voile les articles 9 à
20 modifié par les amendements adoptés
le Sénat à l'article 9 et se proposer ou
accepter par le gouvernement ainsi que
l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023
je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 59 du règlement le scrutin
public et de droit
il va être procédé aux scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 de notre règlement
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
personne ne demande à voter
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin
votant 344
exprimez 307 pour 195 contre 112 le
Sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre dans deux secondes
mes chers collègues nous sommes parvenus
au terme de ce débat très dense dans
lequel chacun s'est exprimé depuis le
Jeudi 2 mars nous avons siégé 10 jours
et quasiment autant de nuit en continu
pour un total de plus de senteurs de
débat
nous avons enregistré un nombre record
d'amendements de sous amendements
8900 au total
le débat a eu lieu à des bacs pu être
éclairé où chacun a pu affirmer sa
position sur chaque partie chaque apport
du sexe sur l'article 7 qu'on peut
qualifier de cœur du réacteur dont nous
avons engagé la discussion le mardi 7
mars au soir nous avons eu 63 prises de
parole sur l'article avant la
présentation des 77 amendements de
suppression d'articles nous avons
débattu plus de 13 heures sur ce seul
article 7 les règles de procédure et
celle fixées par la Constitution
nous conduisent à achever l'examen de ce
texte dans le délai de 15 jours un parti
au Sénat
par-delà nous divergences qui sont
profondes je crois que nous avons pu
mettre l'empreinte du Sénat sur ce texte
je voudrais salué le travail approfondie
de madame le rapporteur général et du
rapporteur de la branche vieillesse et
de la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales
[Musique]
parce que eux ils ont fait les chanteurs
plus le travail en commission plus ce
travail préparatoire j'aurais saluer le
travail de l'ensemble des membres de
votre commission madame la Présidente la
commission ainsi que celui des collègues
sénateurs de l'ensemble des groupes je
voudrais vous remercier Monsieur le
Ministre pour messieurs les ministres
pour
votre présence tout au long de nos
débats ainsi que pour la pédagogie que
vous avez
démontré au cours de ce débat ce travail
va maintenant se poursuivre son chemin
en commission mixte paritaire avant de
nous revenir la semaine prochaine voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire en vous
remerciant mes chers collègues
permettez-moi de remercier
particulièrement les vices présidents du
Sénat qui ont été à la tâche et qui se
sont répartis dans leur vivacité
diversité c'est plus de 100 heures de
débat moi aussi je voudrais
associer l'ensemble j'allais dire
particulièrement du service législatif
et du service de la commission des
affaires sociales qui ont été vraiment
dans une tâche exceptionnelle
[Applaudissements]
pour certains c'était leur baptême du
feu pour d'autres l'apogée presque d'un
premier étape de carrière en vous
souhaitant le meilleur chers madame pour
la suite en tous les cas je voulais vous
dire que j'ai le sentiment d'être le
président d'une institution qui a joué
son rôle et qu'il l'a joué avec
engagement responsabilité avec pour
seule ligne de crête quel que soit nos
sentiments l'intérêt du pays et
l'intérêt des Français
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
vos mots mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs mesdames la présidente de la
commission mesdames messieurs mesdames
et messieurs le rapporteur trois mois à
mon tour d'abord pour vous dire que avec
mon collègue Franck Riester avec Gabriel
Attal qui était présent à nos côtés pour
les articles financiers je voudrais
adresser tous mes remerciements à Madame
la Présidente et Mesdames et monsieur le
rapporteur pour la qualité des relations
que nous avons entretenues pour les
travaux préparatoires les échanges ont
parfois été vifs sur l'importer parce
que nous n'avons nous avions quelques
divergences et il en reste sur ce texte
mais je crois que nous avons fait cela
dans un climat constructif dans un
climat de travail et avec la volonté de
porter un texte et de faire en sorte que
chacun puisse se retrouver et espérer
qu'à la fin de tout ce processus le
texte soit adopté et qu'il puisse être
le meilleur possible je voudrais
remercier tous les sénateurs tous les
sénateurs qui ont participé à ce débat
des présidents de groupe et les
sénateurs parce que je pense que chaque
contribution a été utile que les groupes
ont pu faire valoir des positions les
sénateurs ont pu faire valoir des
positions et à travers ces positions à
travers les amendements qui ont été
adoptés le texte a pu être enrichi sur
la question des orphelins sur la
question des maires de famille sur la
question des agriculteurs des
sapeurs-pompiers du rachat de trimestre
ou encore des élus locaux je sais
combien madame la rapporteur pour avis
et particulièrement attaché nous avons
enrichi ce texte et nous devons je crois
espérer que la suite du débat
parlementaire la commission mixte
paritaire les étapes qui suivront
permettent de l'enrichir encore pour que
ce texte puisse ainsi pour aussi son
chemin législatif la deuxième chose que
je voulais vous dire à vous tous et
peut-être à vous encore plus
particulièrement Monsieur le Président
c'est que beaucoup d'entre vous ont
peut-être pris un peu l'habitude de me
voir depuis quelques années au travers
des différentes fonctions que j'ai
exercé et beaucoup d'entre vous savent
que savent que j'ai toujours beaucoup de
plaisir à retrouver le Sénat débattre au
Sénat et que j'apprécie à la fois la
qualité de vos travaux mais aussi leur
calme et comme les sentiments comme le
plaisir
le plaisir intellectuel la satisfaction
intellectuelle sont des sentiments
relatifs qui se mesure toujours à
l'homme du déplaisir que l'on peut
connaître par ailleurs je l'ai encore
plus apprécié cette fois-ci
et enfin
et enfin monsieur le Président
permettez-moi de m'associer à vos mots
pour l'ensemble des services du Sénat
n'est peut-être pas la coutume mais je
vais à la fois saluer la qualité
l'intensité du travail mais aussi
remercier l'ensemble des services du
Sénat l'ensemble des agents pour la très
grande gentillesse avec laquelle ils
accueillent les membres du gouvernement
nos équipes combien ils peuvent aussi en
même temps qu'il vous accompagnent dans
leur fonction nous faciliter le travail
ici remercier l'ensemble des équipes qui
m'accompagnent sur ce texte évidemment
les services du ministère du Travail des
services du gouvernement mais vous
comprendrez que j'ai une attention toute
particulière pour mon cabinet ils ont un
engagement et un investissement que dont
je suis le témoin le plus privilégié et
qui est absolument absolument
remarquable et enfin dernier point pour
vous dire que je suis particulièrement
heureux parce que parlementaire depuis
2017 quand le Parlement vote et quand le
quand le Parlement légifère merci à tous
merci monsieur le ministre
merci messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance
prochaine séance le mardi 14 mars 2023
14h30 pour la proposition de loi
organique visant à permettre à
Saint-Barthélémy de participer à
l'exercice de compétences de l'État la
séance est levée